>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
It's very nice to see all of
you here ready for this concert.
My name is David Plyler.
I'm in the music division,
and I have the great honor
and pleasure to have
three amazing musicians
up here with me.
At the end, we have
Elliott Fisk,
who you will hear on a guitar.
Irvine Arditti, founder
and patriarch, I guess,
of the Arditti Quartet,
and Hilda Paredes,
whose work we will hear
premiered this evening.
So welcome.
We're so pleased to have you.
>> Eliot Fisk: Thank you.
>> Hilda Paredes: Thank
you for having us.
[ Applause ]
>> David Plylar: At the very
outset, before we get started,
I want to thank the
Mexican Cultural Institute
of the Embassy of Mexico
for their support in helping
to bring Hilda here today, so
that she could speak with us
and experience the
performance, as well.
I thought -- there's
such a variety of music
on this program, I thought
we could just say a few words
about each piece and kind
of go from there and see
where the conversation takes us.
So I thought maybe the place
to start would be the Berio.
There will be an admission,
of sorts, of a fault of mine
with this piece, but --
>> Eliot Fisk: It's
not your fault.
You know, it's always
interesting when things
that you've lived become lines
in some kind of an encyclopedia
or somebody's treatise or
somebody's PhD dissertation
or whatever, you know?
And you remember how you lived
it, and then you see how the,
you know, the musicological
mind deals with what you lived
and what you experienced
as music, and sometimes,
it's quite brilliant what they
have to say, and sometimes,
they just get it a little wrong.
I think this case it's
curious that, in my experience,
what the man wrote
was incorrect.
>> David Plylar: So what
I'm just going to point out,
and I like to -- if I'm
wrong about something,
I want to put it out
there right away.
There's a, in your notes, it's
since been updated, by the way,
in the digital version, in
your notes there is a mistake
about one of the things that
Eliot Fisk supposedly said
to Berio, and I made the
incorrect approach of going
with the secondary source,
when the primary
source is right there.
So this is a good -- this is a
teachable moment with research.
So be aware.
>> Eliot Fisk: It's
really just -- it's just --
>> Irvine Arditti: What
are you talking about?
>> Eliot Fisk: So
almost 30 years ago,
I met Berio in his villa in the
Radicondoli, the famous place
where he wrote a lot of his
music and where he retreated
from the world and just
holed up and wrote things
and had wonderful, big dinner
banquets and things with lots
of people, and it was
a wonderful place.
Basically, it was
similar to Stockhausen.
If you want to write
these people,
you write Maestro Luciano
Berio Radicondoli Italia
vicinoa Siena.
So you write, you know,
Radicondoli is the
name of the town.
Near to Siena.
So you write, you
know, Radicondoli,
it's the name of the town.
Italia, that's Italy.
Near to Siena, that's
the address.
Like Stockhausen used to
be Stockhausen Kurten,
whatever the [inaudible]
was, right?
It was Stockhausen Kurten.
That's all you need for
these to get to these people.
Anyway --
>> Irvine Arditti: It's not
good if you live in London.
>> Eliot Fisk: Then you just
write [non-English word].
It gets there.
But anyway, so, as we
work towards the creation
of a sequenti, it's, perhaps,
not a typical process,
because these sequenzas were
written, really, almost,
at least in my case, almost as a
kind of a portrait of the lunacy
of the person for which
the piece was written,
and I remember when I got
the first draft of it,
and he writes [non-English
spoken].
"Here it is.
The cursed one.
It will make you despair
as it has made me despair."
Anyway, so he wrote, as
you'll hear, there's a short,
quiet introduction, which
was actually added later
at breakfast one morning.
But the short introduction was
added later, but the piece,
it originally started with just
like two chords and
an explosion.
Later, he had a little
bit of an intro
to make the explosion a little
bit -- come a little bit later.
But anyway, he figured
that after about 12 minutes
of just going crazy
on the instrument,
that the instrument
would be out of tune,
which was a logical
assumption, but in fact,
it really didn't get out
of tune most of the time.
And so, there's this optional
place about 10 pages in,
where if you want, you can tune
the instrument, and you'll hear
that there's this sort of place
where things relax for a while.
You can tune the instrument.
Will tonight, since the second
piece has got all scordatura,
meaning change.
Maestro Berio's piece
has lots of changing
of the tuning of
the instruments.
So maybe tonight it will be the
one night that I have to tune,
but I generally don't
tune, and that was --
it was not me that said
anything about having to tune.
That was Berio's idea.
So that's the slight
incorrection that --
>> David Plylar: So the
reason I bring this up,
beyond it just being kind
of interesting in itself is
that the interactions between
composers when they're able
to work the instrumentalists
who are performing
their works is really --
it plays a great role in the
creation of these pieces.
And so, for all of the
pieces, I believe tonight,
there was some aspect of this
where the performers were able
to work with the composers,
or not with the Lachenmann or?
>> Irvine Arditti:
You said everything.
>> David Plylar: Oh, okay.
So in any case, it's just one of
those important things that --
well, one other thing I'd
like to say, or have you speak
about with the sequenza, you
mentioned earlier today that,
in many ways, these
are like portraits,
not so much about any particular
theoretical or technical aspect,
but it's more portraits
of performers and things.
So this aspect of
performer/composer kind
of struck you as that
was being an important --
>> Eliot Fisk: Yeah,
I don't want
to overemphasize my
personal importance.
Of course, there are all
kinds of musical structures
that are being worked
out, and Berio's composing
out the musical DNA, really,
of a certain chord that's
in the piece, and
that's what, you know,
the great composers do.
They compose out the musical --
they establish a musical DNA,
and they compose out
some of the many ways
that DNA might be developed,
as it goes through life,
so to speak, and that's really
more important than my persona,
as far as the piece, of
much more importance.
It just so happened I
had the privilege to work
with Maestro Berio
on this piece,
and we did have a lot
of back-and-forth.
There were a lot of little --
you know, he really knew
the instrument very well,
and actually, you
know, showed me,
as Maestro Paredes actually
has given me a very profound
education about my instrument.
She found all these things
that I thought were
completely impossible.
I still think they're
impossible,
but she's actually
right, you know?
I just have to work harder.
[ Laughter ]
So this is a great
thing, when you work
with a superior musical mind
that doesn't necessarily
play your instrument.
They don't tend to have
a lot of pity on you,
and but this is good,
because it forces you to grow
and to expand your horizons and
to amplify your consciousness,
and this is why we're
grateful, especially tonight,
to have the honor of
Maestro here with us.
It's terrific.
So...
>> David Plylar: Well,
writing for guitar,
if you're a non-guitarist,
I think it's one
of those tricky things
for composers, in general,
but you've written a lot of
pieces that involve guitar
or pluck strings and
things like that.
Maybe you can tell us a bit
about this piece,
this new piece.
>> Hilda Paredes: The
guitar is a big challenge,
if you're not a guitarist
yourself,
but then I don't play violin.
I don't play viola.
I don't play cello, and just,
as you've mentioned before,
working, it is as important for
composer to work with players,
as it is for players
to work for composers.
And we develop all sorts of ways
of understanding the instrument,
and in my case, I tried to
write very idiomatically
and to discover, to draw the
music out of the instrument,
but also, to try to find -- you
see, the more I write music,
the more I discover that music
has its own intelligence,
and the less I have to make
decisions, the more the process
of creation is, for me,
a process of discovery
and a process that sometimes
it's very surprising.
So, I will mention score Datura,
but this has been an issue
that we have been discussing,
and because you mentioned it.
>> Irvine Arditti: That's
why I'm sitting between them.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yes.
[ Laughter ]
The guitar is tuned, the strings
of the guitar are tuned to a way
of thinking, which is
very tonal, very much part
of a harmony that is --
belongs to a certain period
in the history of music,
and for me, the difference
between the guitar and the bowed
instruments in a string quartet,
is precisely that it's a lot
easier to change the tuning.
I never like to change the
tuning of the bowed instruments,
because it creates all sorts
of practical problems
to get the pieces --
>> Eliot Fisk: There's
no problem at all
when you retune three
strings of the guitar.
It's very, very easy.
>> Hilda Paredes: Well, perhaps,
you have to think differently,
but the guitar can
take it more easily.
And this, for me, creates
a whole different range
of harmonic possibilities.
>> Eliot Fisk: Yeah,
this is for sure.
It is amazing.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yes, and
this is, for me, the source --
all the harmonic structure
of the piece is in the hands
of the guitar, in the way the
guitar is tuned differently
in this piece.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Does
the tunings stay --
does it change during
the course of the piece?
>> Eliot Fisk: No, that's --
>> Hilda Paredes: No.
>> Eliot Fisk: At
least that, but --
>> David Plylar: The next piece.
>> Eliot Fisk: But
basically, if you imagine that,
since the sixth string
is in E flat,
the fourth string is D flat, and
the second string is in B flat.
So every other string is
basically has all the notes
shifted one inch, or in
the case of the D flat,
it's even stranger,
because it's a third.
So I know about 10
scoredaturas on the guitar,
something like this,
a lot of scoredaturas.
I know E flat in
the sixth string.
There's one piece by
Takemitsu that uses a B flat
in the second string, and I
don't of any piece except for,
I think, Hilda has another piece
has an even weirder scoredatura.
But aside from that,
I'm not aware of --
I'm not aware, you
know, we don't grow
up with these scoredaturas.
I grew up with about 10
scoredaturas, but not this one.
So it really is a
mental gymnastics,
because she's calling for
lightning-quick reaction.
This repertoire that the
RTT plays requires a kind
of virtuosity.
I mean, I consider -- I
tried to explain to --
to thank them that are really
a more highly evolved form
of human being.
It's like I'm a Neanderthal,
and they are Homo sapiens,
and they have to try
to bring me along.
You know, and I'm not
anywhere near their level,
but they have been so gracious
to me and been so kind to me
in allowing me to sort
of stumble along and try
to enter their wonderful
universe.
>> Irvine Arditti:
What should I say, man?
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Speech ]
No, he's great.
It's just we're slightly more
experienced playing this sort
of music.
I mean, but I think that's
why he wanted to do it.
Isn't that right?
>> Eliot Fisk: Yeah,
it's like jumping
out of a plane the
first time, I guess.
You know, it's -- but not sure
that the parachute
was going to open.
So...
>> David Plylar: Well,
could you tell us a bit more
about the origins of the piece?
I know that the name has a
rather multiple meanings that --
>> Hilda Paredes: Yes, well,
it has sun, the word sun.
It can mean they are
or it can mean sun.
It's a musical form, a
popular musical form, in --
>> Eliot Fisk: Barcos?
>> Hilda Paredes: Eh?
>> Eliot Fisk: Barcocina.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yeah, yeah,
in Mexico, it's a musical form.
The piece has nothing to do
with traditional popular Mexican
music, and the second part
of the title, Dementes Cuerdas,
can mean they are demential
strings or it can mean song,
the musical form, of
demential strings,
or it can also mean they
are of sound of mind
if you divide the word
de-mente-cuerda means --
yeah, it can also mean
they are of sound mind.
So it has multiple
meanings, and for me,
this opens up a whole idea of
the kind of liquidity of --
music doesn't have
a meaning, as such,
or it has so many meanings.
It has as many meanings as
ears or open ears are out there
to listen to it and to allow
the music to get inside them.
So for me, this is very
-- an appropriate title.
It also makes reference,
of course,
to the multiple techniques that
I use in the piece, particularly
in the string quartet.
You going to hear and
see the players do things
that are not very conventional.
>> David Plylar: Yeah, there
are moments in the piece.
I've only been able to listen
through completely just the
once, but there are moments
where it feels like it's
almost turned into a, I guess,
what would be a 22-string
guitar or something like that,
where it really --
it has that effect.
I mean, of course there's
other places where I don't want
to say there's tension between
them, but it's more distinctive,
but there really are these
really especially beautiful
moments when some of the
harmonics kind of pop
out that are really something.
And then, also this mega guitar.
>> Hilda Paredes: Well,
it is many strings there.
So you can -- I play in
the piece there's this --
in the middle section,
there's a very expressive solo
for the guitar, and the string
quartet only shadows the
harmonies, and there's
moments, as you say,
that the whole ensemble
becomes a mega instrument.
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Well, it's
a very beautiful piece,
and we're looking forward to it.
I know this is just the premier,
but do you have plans
to record it or --
>> Hilda Paredes: Hopefully.
Hopefully, we haven't
discussed that.
>> Eliot Fisk: We need
to perform it first.
[ Laughter ]
>> Irvine Arditti: Oh, come on.
You're a master of plucking.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Plylar: He's
also a lot of courage.
>> Irvine Arditti: He can
pluck much better than we can.
[chuckling].
So we learn a lot
from his plucking
and dexterity on the guitar.
>> David Plylar: Well, Eliot,
you're welcome to stay with us,
but I know you also wanted to --
>> Eliot Fisk: Yeah, I think
I will just say see you.
See you out there, and thank
you so much for coming,
and I'm so happy that Library
of Congress could be, really,
the sparkplug for this
wonderful project,
which has been just great to be
part of, and I'm looking forward
to the rest of the tour,
which starts right here.
So thank you.
>> David Plylar: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Maybe we could speak a bit more
about the rest of the program.
As we mentioned at
the very beginning,
there's a wide variety of music.
So each piece is -- kind
of represents something
that's quite different.
The piece that I have not
heard it all is the Manoury,
but you have played all four
of his, or at least all four
of the ones that
he didn't disavow.
>> Irvine Arditti: No,
that's not true, actually.
I read your program notes,
which are quite extensive.
I mean, there's nothing much
more I can say about the piece.
It's all written in the program,
but the very early quartet,
we have a strange relationship
with Philippe Manoury,
because most composers
we work with,
and they write us a quartet,
or whatever the piece is,
and then some years later, they
usually write another piece,
and there's before you
know where you are,
there's a whole repertoire
of string quartets,
usually, from composers.
With Philippe, we
played the early quartet,
which is mentioned
in the program.
We played it in a festival,
I think, in the 80s.
>> David Plylar: Seventy-eight?
>> Irvine Arditti:
Oh, was it 70s?
>> David Plylar: Well, he
said it was composed in '78.
So it would be --
>> Irvine Arditti: I think so.
Yeah, it was soon after then.
I don't remember exactly
when we played it,
maybe in the early 80s, and
I was not particularly fond
of the piece, but we played it
a few times, half a dozen times.
And then, we lost touch.
We didn't ask him
for another quartet,
and there were two French
composers together we played
at that concert.
One was Pascal Dusapin, and the
other one was Philippe Manoury.
I mention that because the last
time we were here we played
for the Phillips Collection,
and we played a quartet
of Pascal Dusapin.
So we met these two composers
when they were young,
and with Dusapin, we
continued the relationship,
and he wrote almost all
his quartets following
that very first one that
we played in this concert.
With Philippe Manoury, we
had stopped having contact
until quite a few years
later, I think at the end
of the 20th century when
he wrote his string quartet
called Stringendo.
And then, he decided,
at some point,
that the early quartet was
not to be played anymore,
and I think in between, I'd
asked him for a quartet,
and he got really upset,
because he wanted us
to play the early one more, and
he said, "I've written you one.
You don't play it."
So there were quite a lot
of years that went by,
early 80s till I don't
remember exactly when the --
>> David Plylar: It
was 2010 was when --
>> Irvine Arditti: Was it 2010?
Okay, so that's helluva
lot of years.
So he wrote -- then
he decided that okay,
Irvine doesn't particularly
like the first quartet.
Perhaps I will withdraw it.
I don't particularly
like it either.
I must say, by this time,
I'm beginning to quite
like it again, but I
do love to be obtuse,
especially with composers.
But then he wrote Stringendo.
Then he wrote another
piece with electronics,
not for us, for a
French quartet.
And then he wrote --
>> David Plylar: Melencolia.
>> Irvine Arditti: Melencolia,
which is a very challenging
piece.
It's like 45 minutes long,
and we have to play crotalas,
as well as our instruments.
And sometimes there's
crotalas bells, and sometimes,
we have a mallet, but
sometimes there's no time
to pick up the mallet.
So you have to the
crotalas with the point
of the bow, the pin of the bow.
It's very challenging.
I don't know if they've
got any good bows here,
but I was thinking of asking
them if I could borrow one,
and we could actually
play it next time.
>> David Plylar: Well, actually,
we have a view Tourte
bows over there.
>> Irvine Arditti:
No, no, Tourtes.
Yeah, no, no Tourtes
to go with that --
>> David Plylar: No, we do
have -- I think we do actually.
>> Irvine Arditti: You do, yeah.
Okay, well, I wouldn't
really ask that.
And then, recently, Stringendo
arrived a couple of years ago,
and it's probably the most
concise of the pieces,
the piece we'll play tonight,
and I like Philippe's writing,
because it almost
goes back to the past.
It's not a minimalism.
It doesn't get up to the antics
that the last piece we'll
play, Lachenmann does.
It's actually going back
to playing the instrument
as I was taught to
play it many years ago,
which is sometimes quite
refreshing from composers,
because we play all
sorts of different music
and are well-known for getting
up to all sorts of things.
And so, in actual fact,
now Philippe Manoury has written
a whole gamut of string quartets
for us, and we continued the
relationship after a long pause,
and going back to the
joke of the first quartet.
We played the other quartets
in a festival in England,
and we wanted to play
something from him.
This was in our 40th
anniversary three years ago.
And the only piece that fit
it was the early quartet.
So I had to phone him
up and say, Philippe,
do you mind if we play
that early quartet
that you said was withdrawn?
And he said, "Okay, Irvine,
you can play it, but once."
So we played it a few years ago.
>> David Plylar: Oh, wow.
Well, you know, something
that you said struck me
as a bit unfair for a
composer to complain about,
which is that, you know,
why haven't you been playing
my piece in the meantime,
because you play so many new
pieces that are written for you
or are just part
of the literature.
One thing that, you know, I
think that, at least I have
as a question, and I'm sure
other people do, as well.
How do you manage to -- they're
such diverse types of pieces
that require so much thought
and care to put together.
How do you go about this
process of planning programming?
Do you do this years in advance?
Do you have like just
rigorous rehearsal schedule
that allows you to
accomplish these things?
>> Irvine Arditti: What would
you like to hear tomorrow?
[ Laughter ]
>> David Plylar: All right.
>> Irvine Arditti: I mean,
there's a core nucleus of pieces
that we can play almost
without any rehearsal,
because we play them so often,
and that's great, because,
I think, you have to be quick
learning contemporary music.
If you take a long time doing
it, you'll never get very far.
I mean, you have to access
the pieces quite quickly
to know what they're all
about, and we do quite a lot
of work before we meet.
We take the parts and the score,
and we put lots of markings in.
So that before the
first rehearsal,
we know exactly what our
colleagues are playing.
And so, it minimalizes
the rehearsal time.
It's like being a conductor,
each being a conductor
and studying the score,
so you know what each instrument
is supposed to do, so your part
in a quartet, your part
in relation to the others.
And then, I think the learning
process becomes quite quick.
Obviously, the piece develops.
You know, if you're playing
a piece for the first time,
it's not going to be the same
as if you're playing
it for the 10th time.
I think we've played Philippe
Manoury's piece now eight
or 10 times.
We've played Grido more
than a hundred times.
>> David Plylar: Oh, wow.
>> Irvine Arditti: And
that's quite a lot,
considering that with a
lot of pieces we've played,
not many other quartets play
those pieces, but with Grido,
there were at least nine or 10
quartets that play that piece.
And considering, you know,
the techniques involved
with Lachenmann's
music, that's changed
over the past 10 or 15 years.
>> David Plylar: Sure.
Well, before we get to the
Lachenmann, I do want to speak
about that a little bit.
Hilda, I was wondering,
maybe you could speak
about your experience of
writing for the Arditti Quartet,
because you've done that
for other pieces, as well,
and is it always a case
where everything's perfect right
off the bat, or do you get a lot
of feedback, or what's
the interaction like?
>> Hilda Paredes: Well, for me,
it's probably the biggest
challenge, I have to say,
and I have written
orchestral music.
I have written operas an ex --
a new opera now, but for me,
the biggest challenge is the
string quartet for these guys.
Why? Because I know the
experience they have.
I know that the stature
of these musicians,
and because I know almost all
the composers they have worked
with, and many of them are
people that I highly respect.
And so, and it's also a medium
that you cannot hide
as a composer.
You cannot just sort
of use the orchestra
to hide behind the big
noise or something.
I mean, everything, everything
you write comes through.
So yes, for me, it's
the biggest challenge.
So,
also, because I sent myself
very high standards when I write
for them, and from the very
first quartet I wrote for them
in '98, these quartets, I had
to make a decision then whether
I would just write string
quartet, or whether
I would write a piece
for the Arditti Quartet,
and I chose the second.
And I think it was a wise
choice, because having made
that decision, I grew as a
composer, because I was able
to challenge myself, and I knew
that anything I would write
they would be able to play.
And that has a double edge, yes?
So the second time
I wrote for them,
I want to the same experience.
I wanted to grow even more,
and in my third quartet,
it was just a more intimate
piece, a tribute to this journey
of 20 years with some
-- which we shared.
And --
>> Irvine Arditti: I have to
tell you, Hilda is my wife,
if you don't know that,
and that's why she's seen
all the composers come
into our house and rehearse with
us, and that's why she lives
with lots of string
quartets being played,
and she's on another floor
trying to write music.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yeah,
so that's -- that's it.
>> David Plylar: Yeah
that's a -- go off track.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Well, it's
always interesting to hear
about these different types of
interactions, because I think
for most people, it's an
unknowable type of thing.
They don't compose.
Although if you don't,
you should compose.
Everybody should
compose, I think.
Going back to the Lachenmann,
which is on the second half,
I'm wondering if you could say
a few words about its origin
and working with Lachenmann,
what that was like.
Because I know one of the
things that you'd mentioned,
some of the different
techniques, especially from some
of the earlier quartets,
part of it is almost seems
like there needs to be a
demonstration or something
like that, in order to
really understand it.
I don't know if you found
that to be the case.
>> Irvine Arditti: Well,
we've had a long relationship,
I have and quartet,
various different members
of the quartet, with Lachenmann.
I like having relationships
with composers.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Plylar:
Right thing to say.
>> Irvine Arditti: But this is a
different sort of relationship,
but going back to Helmut, I
think we first played his music
in '85, and we weren't
very successful.
We played the first
quartet, Gran Torso.
It's a complicated piece.
There's a lot of theater,
motions, in it playing
on the body of the instrument
doing all sorts of things.
And it's rather against
the music.
It was like a protest
at the time,
and we weren't terribly good
at doing that sort of thing.
We started off playing difficult
music, normal, complex music,
and found we could
do it quite well,
but we weren't very
good at making noises.
And it's very funny, because I
think Helmut says he asked the
promoter to have his cost of
travel coming from Germany
to London after the
concert, so he could work
with us more on the piece.
And I didn't know this until
quite recently, but Helmut came
and he stayed, and I think
once he stayed for a week,
we played all his pieces.
There's a great piece
called Tanzsuite for quartet
and orchestra, which
we've done many times,
and after Gran Torso, both of
the next quartets were written
for us, Reigen seliger
Geister and Grido,
which we play tonight.
And so, we really had a
great relationship with him.
I think you have
to know composers.
You have to understand them,
as well as understanding them.
I mean, I started
playing contemporary music
when I was very young.
I knew Ligeti.
I knew everybody.
I knew Carter.
I knew Cage.
And if you have some knowledge
of the way people react,
you have meals with
them, or they come
and stay with you to rehearse.
I Xenakis very well.
I feel qualified as a kind
of link to play their music,
because I understood
exactly what they wanted.
And of course, there are
hundreds of other composers,
less well-known people
also, of a tradition
that one can pass down.
But Helmut's a very special
character, because he works
out all his techniques.
You can actually
do them himself,
even though he can't
really play the instruments,
and all the techniques that he
asks for, he can demonstrate,
and I love getting him
to demonstrate things,
because he holds the instrument
in a very odd way, the violin
and the bow, but the way he
holds it is the most perfect way
to realize what he's written.
And so you, just by
looking at what he does,
sometimes we have
fun in workshops.
I give him my violin, and
I just watch him again
and see what he does and how
easily he gets these sounds.
And of course, you're
not taught.
You naturally, as a
violinist or a string player,
you don't hold the
instrument in that way,
and I remember the reason
we were unsuccessful
in the beginning was because all
these weird ways he taught us
to hold the bow, in the
panic of the concert,
you just forget them, and you go
back to what you normally know.
And it takes a while,
it takes a few concerts
of playing his music
to understand exactly
what you have to do.
And for some of the
rehearsals we had with him,
we'd work independently
one-and-a-half days,
each player, and the
important thing was
to learn the techniques.
The rehearsing of the pieces, we
could do in a way without him,
but to understand from
the beginning what we had
to do was the most
important thing,
and if you really understand
from the beginning,
you rehearse right.
So many people do not do their
homework at the beginning
and rehearse wrong, and
then they perfect wrong.
And then, they're very
good at playing it wrong,
and then they find it very
difficult to play it right
when somebody says, "No-no,
you have to do it like this."
And so, that's why,
from the very beginnings
of the Arditti Quartet,
I realized the importance
of actually working with
composers, rehearsing pieces
with the composers fairly
early on in the relationship
between you and the
piece, even, perhaps,
before you can play it properly,
is to find out what they want,
so you can point
your interpretation
in the right direction.
And for me, that's one of
the most fascinating things
about playing contemporary
music.
It's something you can't do with
classical composers, of course.
You can't phone them up.
>> Hilda Paredes: Or email them.
>> Irvine Arditti: Or email
them, or all the other things
that you can do these days.
>> David Plylar:
Right, too many though.
Well, you know, another thing
that I think that's interesting
to maybe say about that
is that, in essence,
you're kind of establishing
a performance practice
that can then -- so
that it almost seems
like a master-apprentice
relationship in terms of how
that type of knowledge
gets passed on,
because it's not always
so easy to, I think,
glean from just a recording
or just the score as it is
with that one-on-one
interaction.
>> Irvine Arditti: Yeah, I mean,
that's the great responsibility
what we do, being the bearers
of the sound of so many
pieces for the first time.
That's a huge responsibility.
I remember thinking about that,
or rather, try not to think
about it in the early days.
We do concerts at
important music festivals,
and the things would
be broadcast live.
Today, they're often
streamed, too.
They'd make recordings.
They'd issue them on documentary
CDs from the festival,
and you knew there was no
place to try out these pieces.
You know, you couldn't
try out them
in some not-important
venue first.
You had to get it
right the first time,
and this is a great
responsibility,
and it's something you
have to take seriously.
So it means you work
very quickly
and very accurately
towards your end goal.
>> David Plylar: Well, I have
a question for both of you.
I thought if you could
say a few words --
you mentioned an opera earlier.
I don't know if you can say
anything about that yet,
or maybe just speak about some
of your upcoming projects.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yes, I am just
starting writing a monodrama,
an opera project based
on an American --
a very important American
person from the 19th century,
Harriet Tubman, and it's been
the most incredible journey
so far, the past 18 months, the
process, the research process.
I was very ignorant
about this --
about Harriet Tubman
and this period
in the history of North America.
And I'm very grateful to the
African-American soprano,
Claron McFadden,
for introducing --
I'm writing the piece for her,
for introducing me to her,
and hopefully, it will be --
it's already a wonderful
journey, and hopefully,
it will continue to be one.
The piece is programmed
for the autumn of 2018,
and it's actually a commission
from a Mexican festival.
And the press --
I'm sure we will,
eventually, bring it to the US.
I'm not so sure what the plans
are, but it's a coproduction
with a music theater
transplant in Belgium.
Claron McFadden lives
in the Netherlands.
So that's the connection,
and we are hoping
to tour the piece
quite, quite widely.
>> David Plylar: Oh, fantastic.
>> Hilda Paredes: Yes.
>> David Plylar: And what
about the Arditti Quartet?
>> Irvine Arditti:
Oh, don't ask me that,
what we're doing tomorrow.
I'm thinking about
what we're doing today.
>> David Plylar: Sure, sure.
Well, maybe, you know, well,
you're probably just doing a lot
of new pieces that
we'll get to hear.
I mean, we've all been
the beneficiaries --
>> Irvine Arditti:
It's French year.
The spring is French year
-- both two other composers,
one who we have had a
relationship, Hugues Dufourt.
He's just written his
third quartet for us,
which we will play in a few
months' time, and another one,
Philippe Hurel, who
we have never --
I don't think he's
written a string quartet.
What key is your suite in?
[ Laughter ]
I don't think he's
written many quartets,
but he's just also
written a piece for us.
>> David Plylar:
Well, fantastic.
>> Irvine Arditti: So
we've got two new pieces
from French composers.
Completely coincidental
that they arrived.
One is being premiered
in Vienna, and I think,
the other one in Germany
in the [inaudible]
in New Music Days
in two months' time.
>> David Plylar: Well, I
thought maybe, at this point,
we could open it up if there
any questions in the audience.
What I'll ask you to
do is Jay will come
around with the microphone,
just so everybody
can hear the question
and we keep it on the recording.
>> Hi, question for you, Hilda.
It's still very rare,
at least in America,
to have a classical music
composer who was a woman,
and just wondered how you got
started, how you were interested
in beginning to compose, sort
of your progress along the
way there, and for you,
I was asking a lot of people
who've written for you
for your quartet,
are there any --
this is politically incorrect,
but are there anybody who's
avidly wanting to write for you
that you're not interested in.
You don't have to name names.
Does that ever come up?
>> Irvine Arditti: Who do
you want to answer first?
>> Hilda Paredes: I think
things have changed enormously
from the time when I started.
As a young woman, I was always
the only lady in the class,
and this has changed
more and more.
There was some years ago where
the girls outnumber the boys.
So, and I feel there are now
wonderful lady composers,
a lot of my colleagues
whom I respect enormously
and some here in
this country also.
And we're all very different,
and we all have unique voices,
and I find, often, the
music as inspiring as that
of male colleagues,
which wasn't the case
when I started as a student.
I think we still have
a long way to go,
because there's some
environments sometimes
that don't feature
lady composers as much
as they should, or they feature
them too much to make a point
that it has to be
women composers,
as if we are blind autistic nuns
or something like
that, you know?
So hopefully, there will not
be a need to have festivals
of women musicians one day.
>> Irvine Arditti: I must say,
in the Arditti Quartet's
repertoire, we have quite a lot
of women composers and
new people, young people,
and there's a woman composer
writing a piece later
on in the year for a
festival [inaudible].
You've never heard of her,
but her name's Clara Iannotta.
She's probably in her early 30s.
I mean, there's a huge amount
of female composers
on our repertoire
So, I mean, what you're
saying was true long time ago.
It's not really true anymore,
not, at least, in Europe.
I don't know if it's
true the states.
I doubt it.
Do people I don't like
want to write pieces?
It's more people that nobody
knows who want to write pieces
who can't because
nobody knows them.
And if they're great and they
send in a marvelous score,
which I try to look at all
the scores that come in,
then it might be possible.
I think the people who I don't
like know I don't like them
[ Laughter ]
Or let's say we are good
at certain things and not
so good at other things.
And so, everyone knows
what sort of music we play,
and I don't think those people
want to write us pieces anyway.
So it's the way it
is, but it works.
The system works, and I can even
talk to the people I don't like.
Another hand.
Oh, sorry.
>> Hilda, could you share
with us what does it mean
to be a Mexican composer
living in London
and what role does the Mexican
musical, tradition still has
in your role as a composer?
>> Hilda Paredes: It's a
big responsibility for me,
because since I was a
student, I was very aware
about the expectations
that the music industry had
from someone coming
from where I come from,
and it's still the case.
You know, there's a lot
of expectations just
because a Mexican that I'm going
to be writing the unta-unta-unta
kind or some jarocho tonight
or something like that.
And I have been very --
I dislike that extremely,
extremely.
I find it extremely patronizing.
I think there is great, great
ignorance about our history,
about the incredible,
rich culture that we have,
and it's that the European
influence didn't finish.
We are a mixed breed, and
throughout the 20th century,
their been has been
so much immigration
from so many countries that
have enriched our own culture
and have enriched my music.
So for me, it's a
big responsibility,
because I feel I am writing
Mexican music, but not the music
that that industry
of entertainment thinks
Mexican music should be.
Yes?
>> David Plylar: We
have another question.
>> This is for Hilda, as well,
but it could be for both of you.
In doing your research for your
monodrama on Harriet Tubman,
will you and your partner have
time to go to the eastern shore
of Maryland and see some of
the places where she lived.
I believe there's a new Harriet
Tubman Museum that just opened,
and the other question is,
I believe your first opera was a
joint experimental theater piece
based upon the experiences of
immigrants, migrants trying
to cross between north -- across
the border, or am I quick to --
and are there any plans for that
opera to be performed in London,
Berlin, or Washington?
Thank you.
>> Hilda Paredes: I think the
piece your mentioning was not my
first opera.
It's my most recent
music theater piece.
It's La tierra de la
miel, which is part
of a collaborative
project, Cuatro corridos,
which was a collaboration
with three other composers.
There was four of us, and what
ties the four pieces is a story
of the Mexican writer
Jorge Volpe.
This links with your
other question.
I work a lot, particularly,
with Mexican poets
and Mexican writers.
So it was -- the subject
matter, it was a true story,
and it's based on the human
trafficking that women that come
from -- thin and single.
They're brought into this
country as prostitutes,
and this was a story that
hit the New York Times
because it was the cartel
that was bringing --
the gang of people that were
bringing these women were
discovered by Chicana
policewoman,
and they were brought
to justice,
and the whole thing
was dismantled.
So in a way, it's
a happy ending,
but we know that these
things still happen.
>> Irvine Arditti: Was it
done on the East Coast?
It was done first in San Diego.
>> Hilda Paredes: It
was done in San Diego
with the story took place.
Yes, and it has toured a lot,
the United States, and the CD is
out there in Bridge
Records also.
So this is like my
most recent one.
For some reason, a lot of my --
every project I do for the stage
has a lot of political or social
or gender connotations.
And so, the invitation
to do something
on Harriet Tubman was just the
kind of thing that was made
for me, because I
really feel very strongly
about these issues.
I think they are not exclusive
to this country, not exclusive
to the problems with slavery
and to African-Americans.
I think they're more
universal and more humane.
I wish the project had
enough funds for me to travel
to Maryland with my librettist
and my stage director.
We're really struggling to find
the funds for this project,
and it's a very small project.
We'll have three instruments,
electronics, one singer,
and a girl, and that's it.
[ Speaking off Mic ]
So the stage director --
yes, Matthew Lutton
is from Australia.
Mayra Febres is a Puerto Rican
writer, Mayra Santos-Febres,
who is a specialist on slavery
and all these subject matters.
So we are communicating
through Skype and FaceTime.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: I
think we have time
for just one more
question if there is one.
All right, well,
thank you so much.
You're in for a real
treat tonight.
This is some really
gorgeous music and really,
just exciting music, too.
So I'm really excited about it.
And thank Irvine
Arditti and Hilda Paredes
for joining us for this talk.
>> Hilda Paredes: Thank
you for having us.
>> David Plylar: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.